[Music]
[Applause]
you hear that God's a refreshing
Christmas sound right there that is a
Friedrich Hallberg Friedrich tall burg
with Christmas morning number two right
there bringing us in here on this
beautiful and I mean beautiful December
11th that music you've heard that music
right there before that's kind of like
when on that home alone movie when Kevin
finds the you know when it's when it's
finally Christmas morning and everything
is at peace you know you hear it listen
[Music]
with the freshly fallen snow and he
comes outside of his door
and there's his mom
[Music]
or the world is okay the world is okay
you know that's that beautiful moment
music and that's friedrich Thalberg and
he's coming at just somewhere probably
from Germany or Hungary out there in the
wild and the wild of Europe
Friedrich he could almost picture an old
man with a candle you know dog laying
next to him dogs probably been dead for
two years
Friedrich has no idea though he's just
just there writing that music Oh
Friedrich Dahlberg this is kind of like
if you ever seen if ever been it worked
at a hospital and they you know sometime
they have a gay man or even just a kind
of a wild straight man comes in and he
got something crazy he's been put into
his but you know and it could be an
animal whirl you know a wild a vase or
something you know kind of a small vase
or anything like that and this is that
music when they finally pull it out you
know you know what I'm talking about
let's hear one more time they trying to
pull a dove out of some fellas buttocks
right here
Oh looks like they might get it a little
more morphine
[Music]
crazy yo praise the Lord I got a dove
I got a dove out of my buttocks and that
happens man it's that time of year and
it is that time of year Merry Christmas
Happy Holidays Happy Hanukkah happy
Kwanzaa you know they always throw
Kwanzaa in there for like the black
community but you never hear anybody
that celebrates it you know it's like
you know let's I mean I guess it's good
but I think there's a few other holidays
out there and on Thursdays episode we're
going to delve into a little bit more
the you know that some of the holiday
attractions and Christmas vibe from
around the world
just a couple though in advance you know
in South Africa they eat fried
caterpillars this time of year and
that's a delicacy and I've actually had
those in South Africa I've been there
and I've had those treats over there
them crawling treats and over there
something you know here I mean in
America we don't animals get more rights
because we don't need them as much you
know animals get extra rights here
you know you might see two gay dogs
getting married here in New Hampshire or
in you know over in in Albuquerque you
might see a couple of gay Dobermans out
there you know doing sex and looking for
rich ring shopping
you know you might see a here in Beverly
Hills you'll see you know last year they
had a famous Bichon that a lady tried to
get a nose job for it for a Bichon just
because you know it wasn't you know it
wasn't appeasing some of the selfies and
stuff she was taken for her it wasn't
good enough you know and you'll see um
you know you'll see someone out here
with like uh you'll see like sometime
like a tender mannequin with like a veal
but like a baby goat that he rescued or
something now he's walking it over there
on Santa Monica Boulevard or in West
Hollywood but that's just because you
don't have nests you don't have a
necessity for the animals here you know
you get up into Montana you get up into
Mississippi they got people they'll they
see a deer they're gonna gun it down
you know and but they're gonna eat it
they're not just you know it's that
they're not just drive-by shooting
animals you know they use them the
animals are of necessity and when you
get out there to Africa you get out
there to the big black continent you
know the big that big mysterious that
Mother Earth and that thing is just the
damn womb of the world if you haven't
been Africa and looked into an African
man's eyes all right that's where they
got the idea for Lion King if you
haven't look I've been a thing I'm in
Africa maybe six seven times and you
look into a Kenyan man's eyes you can
see the beginning of humanity and I know
that might sound wild to you but their
eyes just go so much deeper then then a
lot of other than a lot of the eyes here
in America because we got new eyes here
you know this country's only been around
for so long you know but you get into
though you get into the depth into those
you know visual swimming pools
you know there's wading waters that are
sitting in a you know in an African
man's skull you can really and I'm
serious here you can see back into the
almost the beginning of time you know a
lot of people out there looking in space
Elon Musk out there hunting around in
space how to travel through time well
I'll say this if you shoot you fire me
good and hard and concise and you
organized me enough and you shoot me
right into a into a into a real black
African man's eye sockets I bet you I
show up a million years in the past then
I'll be back there just bait just
bareback riding a damn Vala raza sock
discuss you know I'll be back there I'll
be back there on one of them snack I
dactyls you know and those are beautiful
animals that only snacks imagine that no
meals lunch dinner breakfast brunch [ __ ]
all that snack adecco
eats when it wants to it doesn't live by
these codes a snack an echo eat when it
wants to other people sitting down for
dessert a snack adapt or break out a
bowl of [ __ ] cereal at 4:00 a.m.
because that's how they behave
but anyway Africa they eatin
caterpillars over there it's a tradition
and that's real in Sweden they got that
you'll goat in Sweden notorious for the
Yule goat or labo okay and I met a
couple of Swedish girls when I was in
Europe one time and a buddy of mine a
Dominican fellow tried to get me to
sleep with him and they may have been by
American standards we were young they
were young I'm gonna leave it right
there everybody was a you know kind of
just you know fresh ages but I told my
buddy I said I don't know man this
seemed like a reach you know it seemed
like a reach if this girl all know who
the Black Crowes are that's why you know
they're like what what what age is too
young to make love to a woman I'm like
if she don't know who the Black Crowes
are you know that's why that's where I
at least gonna reconsider I'm gonna
phone a friend
you know before I dig down into some
young territory but that girl told me
when I met her that Olli boki Olleh
Olleh ball came I believe was the
sweetest term for Santa Claus but Santa
have the Yule goat Sweden I'm sorry
Sweden has that you'll goat and the Yule
goat is is isn't a real animal that's
what it says here
it's typically made almost entirely of
straw in the Swedish tongue the
Christmas goat is known as the your book
though your book origins are rooted in
mythology but it's but it's been warmly
adopted by the Swedes as part of modern
Christian tradition perhaps too warmly
the Swedish town of God
Gavril has erected a giant version of
the Yule goat since 1966 and every year
since people have tried to torch it
kidnap it and even gut it even though
it's just made a straw at least 28 of
the 45 Yule goats have been have been
torched so they're burning goats out
there in Sweden they're burning goats
you know and in Los Angeles you
we could even have a straw goat you know
you couldn't even have a straw a straw
go down here you could even have it
without some limp yella Muppet you know
telling you that it's inhumane you know
without some damn amoeba of a human with
no spinal column who's never done
anything except lived off the internet
never made any choices for themselves
never even thought a tool belt was a you
know uh something they made tools on
without some damn cinnamon licorice
cranberry jelly cranberry sauce eaten
just tadpole telling you can't own a
straw goat it ain't right you know what
it's a straw goat it should be free it's
just what about it's never gonna find
its straw parents hush it up guy that's
not a real thing so those are some
things that go on in the world and I'm
gonna get into more of those on
Thursday's episode just examine and kind
of Christmas around the world and and
just what it what it means to some
people you know and what it is and and
I've just been [ __ ] stressed man I've
been stressed out and to be honest a lot
of my stress is coming from I just been
being lazy I've been feeling depressed
honestly and uh and how that shows up
for me is you know I will I'll stay up
kind of screwing around on the internet
looking at stuff watching videos and
this and that and then I won't get to
sleep at a proper time and then I'll
stay up you know they don't want to get
sleep regular amounts the next thing you
know I'm not up till 11:00 and the next
thing you know them just succumbed with
all the things that I want to do you
know because my brain has a to-do list
that never ends so then I get depressed
because I'm not getting all my stuff
done you know so I just sometimes like
get in this cycle where I'm just not you
know I'm not choosing to take care of
myself and to do the things that I need
to do
to feel healthy you know and to feel you
know it's just like I make my own stress
it's so bizarre to me because I don't
want to be doing that you know I want to
be being productive and it's that time
of year where it's like just a good time
to help others and to not think about
myself but then here I find this just
this depression sneaking in so it's been
kind of frustrating you know and some of
it is just getting up and going you know
I did some yoga at the house you know
but it's like I'll get into bed and I'll
just feel I don't know I'll just feel
depressed I'll feel angry then I start
off I look at social media of course
that makes you mean Twitter will make
you choke out a cousin you know so it's
just been hectic it's been hectic man a
little bit a switch medication you know
I take antidepressants and and so I
switched from one of those because
making me sleepy so I think that could
be part of it and I switched back to an
old one I used to take but they say
there's that transition zone in there a
couple weeks and then any depressant
when you get off the oppresses when you
get off the impresses you I mean that's
when people will somebody fly a plane
into a you know into a senior citizen
cafeteria you know that's those type of
people you know people burn down a
library you know that's what that's when
people aren't making good choices when
they're switching gears and so that's
where I feel like maybe I'm just going
through a little bit of a switching
gears so I am grateful that you guys are
here with me today because this was
something that I have to do you know and
this gave me something to do today
and if you want to know how depression
works for me man not trying to Debbie
down or nothing but it you know I'll
tell you you know it's like I get like
my life is cool my life is cool today
when I really look at it from an
outsider's perspective you know tonight
I'm performing I got a show a Late Show
at the Comedy Store they have their
holiday party you know some of my
favorite comedians and friends will be
there the staff of the Comedy Store
the book are the managers you know some
of these people are real friends of mine
like people that I just really care
about in my heart and they're gonna be
there I'm going to see my buddy Simon
Rex is coming over we're gonna go see
our buddy James Blake who's a musician
who's also one of the just a novel young
thinker and I've gotten to spend some
time with the man and he's just
emotionally aware and curious a neat
fella and in Simon is a new friend of
mine from this year you know when I look
back I'm just so grateful to have new
friends you know so there's a lot of
things and just are obvious in front of
me that I get to do that are fun you
know but still I wake up this morning
with this feeling like I just don't have
any purpose you know like sometimes it's
like my I wish my heart or my brain
could remember the truth instead of just
immediately wander into the non reality
you know into the into the lies you know
the lies that are like well I'm a bad
person or the lies that like I don't
care about other people or the lies you
know I'm just thinking about myself but
my brain will go there my brain will
just you know it's it's just it's
unfortunate that we're I want to say
gifted but we are in infected with with
this that I'm infected with this brain
you know this Despres it's a depressive
brain sometimes and I didn't want to
talk about it today a little bit because
you know wanted to just boost
everybody's spirits and be alive and
just show gratitude but that's okay you
know I can still show gratitude and be
excited about certain things but at the
same time be honest about you know
what's going on
so you know thankfully today I finally
got up and out of bed around 1:00 I
didn't get to bed till about 3:00 but I
got up in bed a bed around 1:00 and a
lot of it was cuz I you know I had to do
the podcast you know how to prepare I
had to get ready you know I got a
producer came to help today Chris Perez
Latino fella you know and he coming in
here with these Latin ideas and stuff
like that you know
then pinata junkies they out there so
and I'm Paul and I'm I'm I'm uh coming
in half Nicaraguan you know so we got
that route we got that Spanish route a
little bit so I had to get up and you
know show some excitement for that so I
guess I'm really grateful today I'm
grateful to you guys for being here for
me because this is something that I've
committed to and it's a commitment that
I'm you know not giving up on so I got
up I made a gratitude list that's one
thing I've been doing good about doing
you know I'll just list off ten things
that I'm grateful for and it can be
anything you know from you know just
getting some rest or you know having
teeth you know cuz you see some dudes
that are just missing grillwork you know
some do this uh he got the you know his
grills look like his took him on some
strong propane a couple times because he
blew a couple of pieces out you know and
uh and I get going and now already I'm
kind of feeling better honestly since I
just kind of said that to you guys real
really in my chest I can just feel a
little bit more excited a little bit
more you know I don't a little bit more
free cuz it's just like this prison that
sometimes just I don't know I can't even
explain it it's like because I don't
mean I haven't really been that
depressed this year and this is one of
the first years that I haven't when I
really look back at my life and I think
a lot of that is it's probably due to
this podcast and keeping me you know
giving me something to look forward to
do and a lot of you guys calling in and
sharing your thoughts and feelings and
stuff that's going on with you and your
lives it makes me feel like you know
like I don't want to let
guys down either by not showing up and
being here so thank you for you know a
little bit of teamwork I guess because I
just didn't feel good you know and
sometimes there's not even a reason for
it you know people like why don't you
feel good I'll be like cuz cuz I'm
probably used to not feeling good for a
lot of my life and and sometimes my
brain goes back there because I guess
it's comfortable I don't know why I
don't know why I don't have an answer
actually sometimes I just don't feel
good so that's it I didn't do anything
bad you know I didn't do anything wrong
I mean I probably could have got out of
bed and got active that's what I should
have done
I started thinking too much and so you
know I started thinking and instead I
took an action I got out and I got
cruising and I'm here today with you
guys so I'm thankful for that 100% and I
am burnin know you'll goats boy they
bout to be hunting straw goats out there
but back to my original thought now so
in some places they kill animals they
need them it's a necessity and when you
get to Africa okay when you get to that
big a you know where Indiana Jones went
a couple times looking for treasure when
you get there you see a couple of
caterpillars go by that's like bison
okay that is moving lunch right there in
places where people are starving and
that's real stuff so you get over there
that's a real deal you know people like
you hear that in the middle of the night
dome like I think I hear something and
somebody look outside and it's just a
caterpillar but that don't mean anything
it means you get the spears out cuz
that's lunch you know that could be
dinner and I'll tell you this story I
was in Vietnam I might have told this
story before I have a very short term
long term memory loss and I was in
Vietnam and you know you can go to the
markets there and they kill an animal
right there for you in the market
you know what I'm saying you wanna uh
you want an hour you want a little bit
of I will meet chop-chop
get and next thing you know they got a
you know they got the owl right there
they got a you know I'm no birth
certificate this ain't no Cabbage Patch
[ __ ] cutleries Cutler replaced this
is the real deal they got an owl
you know chump chop you know they got a
um aardvark you want a little bit of
aardvark next thing you know they
cracked cracked open a spine of a hard
bargain you know and they got it you
know they porn the marrow into a cup and
they dip in you out a couple of a couple
of a couple of arc medallions you know
next thing you know you rolling out of
there with eight little cuts of you know
vark so people you know you go into
these Vietnamese markets anything is a
meat what do you want you want a little
bit I mean look dude it for something if
some bit some visitors went missing did
I guarantee you they'd show up on a menu
in a market you want two panels of Cathy
huh you want a couple grams uh Andy we
got him so I went in there and I was
thinking you know with these American
thoughts you know went in there like oh
they got a pit they had a couple of uh
pigeons in there you know or might have
been what is it um some of God's
Canaries you know a couple partridges
that a couple partridges in there in a
cage you could buy them you know dollar
a partridge so I'm thinking I'll get me
a partridge I'm gonna set it free I'm
gonna change the game you know I'm gonna
be this big you know fancy fella here
I'm gonna come in here and show these
vietze how to change the game by setting
animals free dude I bought one dollar
for uh Parkers right get that Partridge
I'll run outside I mean this is my
moment in the Sun you know this is my
this I'll let that that Partridge loose
man I tell you immediately eight
different Vietnamese people jumped on
this parkas they had a one do pulled a
sword out of his belt and went right at
the park
dude another dude came rolling off of a
tree branch drop down on a rope and try
to snatch for it another I mean people
came it was like it was choreographed by
the Lord
it was just not just eight different
levels of Partridge attackers and one
guy got to it first right grabbed it
right out there in the wild no open in a
in a parking lot by a Vietnamese market
snapped its neck did a nip neck snap on
that Partridge you know I'm not talking
l5 s1 did I'm talking he'll 9 I'm
talking about an up top snapped its neck
and just put it right on his shoulder
because the Vietnamese have small little
shoulders you know barely could hold a
book on them barely could really hold a
small book or a notepad you kind of
probably comfortably set a notepad but
they got very very small shoulders and
he walked off and that's when I realized
wow yeah animal rights definitely but uh
but these people aren't killing these
partridges over here because for fun
that man was going home
that man was going to have Thanksgiving
dinner or whatever you know Vietnamese
holiday supported their a meal that man
was going to feed his family so I guess
if you got a meal man get your meal you
know I know I'm gonna go over to
Mississippi this year for Christmas Eve
I spend my Christmas Eve in Mississippi
and you know that's somebody give me
share sharing up a rare meat over there
you know and I'll do it off dude I will
I will find a way to get a little bit of
Dove or some venison or he'll if they
had vark I'd have a slice of that you
know I don't know what they'll have you
know turtle you know a little bit of
horse or something whatever all right
let me get into this as always think our
charter sponsor gray block pizza gray
block pizza you know where it is it's on
Pico Boulevard heading towards the beats
in los angeles and if you want a slice
you want something treaty go to grey
block pizza i'll name my pizza they have
right now the deep cheese
and I got deep and cheesy on that read
also if you want to know why movies
aren't good anymore and this is if you
don't believe it then you're wrong
I think anyway actually I don't even
know some people maybe if you like
Marvel and all that movies and that's
just what you like that's fine but I
like a little bit of more I like a
little Shawshank you know I like a
little bit of um what other movie do I
like Castlevania that was a video game
but I still I like something a little
bit more got the dark art spending you
know I like um Bridges of Madison County
I like Field of Dreams I like a movie
that's got a little bit of touch you
know I like a movie that reaches down
your throat and just kind of kind of
plays with your heart a little that's
what I like and I find that a lot of the
films aren't entertaining anymore and
it's because there's only a couple of
Studios making films these days it's so
limited it's so specific you got to go
through why are Seth Rogen and James
Franco doing a movie every six months
because it's a formula and only you know
though the studio just worked with these
guys they know we put in a hundred
million we're gonna make 20 million
we're fine with this model we don't care
that's why we have to care as consumers
and now we can with live tree adept go
to live tree dot-com because a live tree
is changing the entertainment industry
by creating a new platform called adept
the public us will be able to fund what
they want to watch own what they help
produce decide who's in it and what goes
on through the processes of content
creation funding and distribution that's
like imagine FanDuel but for the
entertainment industry and I know that's
just my own description but that's what
I'm telling you is that you can own what
is being created and you can ever say so
and who creates it go to live tree Li ve
TR EE dot org actually go to live tree
com Li ve TR e e.com and we got a couple
new sir
some people been asking him for him we
got this past weekend onward shirts up
on theof on comm slash store and a lot
of people been respecting this hair has
been coming in this year you know it's a
one thing sometimes it makes me feel a
little bit different or a little bit
unique and we got a shirt up special on
that and it says you ain't you ain't got
the balls to grow the falls that's what
it says and it's got a picture that uh
the sweet gender-neutral hairstyle
that's flowing off the back of my own
head right now and this is
gender-neutral cuz you want a job today
you want equality well I'm gonna be a
living example of equality because I'm
gender-neutral out here all right I'll
do it I'll fold my nuts into something
if you want to contest it I will fold my
nuts into a you know do some that or or
a vag on me I'll do some more of a Jame
and fold my nuts into something because
I'll come across I'm coming across you
know because we got a we got a we got to
stick together you got to be a lady at
some points you be a lady you know some
time I want to be you don't think I want
to be a big beautiful woman sometimes
you know get a cutlass and straight-up
chill eat some lemon cookies and
breastfeed something then you are you're
dead wrong did i breastfeed a damn adult
boy but a lemon cookie in my jaw Gang
Gang call me rosemary you know sometimes
we all go through some things I some I'm
gonna lay in bed you know sometimes I
want to lay in bed and watch little
women you know or watch um you know Care
Bears and or something and have girls
snacks sometimes I want to that's okay
it doesn't make me a bad person it
doesn't make women a wrong person or a
wrong gender teamwork man what's going
on out here this past weekend a lot of
fires a lot of fires they they setting
it off you know Chelsea Handler had to
escape her from her home kind of a
bummer I wouldn't mind if she did call
a couple of flames to the jaw you know
I'm not a Chelsea Handler fan I am NOT a
Chelsea Handler fan I just I have
trouble with the elitists just speaking
down other people cuz I don't think it
solves anything
you know and I'm not saying that maybe I
don't do it at times you know when I
think I'm better than someone that I
speak down to them but if I do do what I
want to find ways so that I don't I
don't like I don't know that [ __ ] just
burns my balls open sometimes but you
know what I do I pray for swear dude
praying just because I need to get that
if I got if I got that hey to have that
anger in me I got to let that go that's
not gonna do anything for me that's my
issue if I got it you know but I swear
some of these disconnected people I'm
just like what is are you serious this
you have do you know what it's like to
be a human you know what it's like to
have any sort of struggle in the world
just sitting up in your billion-dollar
perch tell them people the California
wildfires they got a video of a man
chasing a rabbit out there and do if you
ask me the rabbits trying to get away
from this man you know that dude seemed
like a stray lark he's out there
catching bunny that dude is out there
catching bunny dude that dude that
rabbit tried three times to get away
from that guy
you know I'm both dumb one of them
seeing they a Mike they might have been
a little bit tender you know coming in a
little bit soft in the thighs one of
them seem like they might have been a
little bit uh you know like they might
have just you know what I'm saying man
one of them they seem like they might
have been you know you might be failable
to find him on Grindr later you know
little Larry or little Lance or little
even the rabbit maybe the rabbit looked
like he was trying to maybe hop into
some things but there was a lot of fires
man I woke up to that video I know
everybody saw it the one where the guys
just driving and there's a the three
road markers or the the green sign you
just see the hills is roasting in the
difference like in the distance like
just like a little baby Mordor
and that's a no joke that is probably
three miles from my house so it's close
man you know a lot going a little bit of
smoke in the air people wearing masks
though come on I still lady at the
supermarket got a mask on some just ear
Muppet you can't handle a hit of air
take a swig off of some air did I
remember when I was growing up they
burned everything in the ditch did if
you didn't want it or you didn't want
somebody else to have it burn it in the
ditch ditch fires man ditch fires
everything you running jump over them
feel that heat on your crotch oh you had
to open your legs to get across that
ditch and you feel that feel that
fricking feel a little bit of stream
hits you you know you feel that hit it
was fun man a smell of a little bit of
burning in the air I miss that it's like
I can't a little bit of a that campfire
vibe you know but yeah people's burning
out here and they got you know rich
people just riding down the hills on
basically on the backs of their workers
you know I wouldn't be surprised to see
you know Rosie O'Donnell just surfing
down the hill on the back of a Latino
yard worker you know Esteban plank
because I got to get down this hill
but yeah I was taking out some of the
risks of fires hunting the rich you know
what's going on what's going on but that
man trying to get that rabbit that seems
very questionable to me seems like they
either knew each other or one of them
had ulterior motives do y'all just
happen to meet up on the side of the
road whatever what else
small town in Ireland proves that not
all air pollution is bad the luck of the
Irish strikes again as a small town in
Ireland is getting a little secondhand
high off a nearby viagra Factory whose
fumes are polluting the airs
that's true local bartender Debbie
O'Grady describes the air as one whiff
and yell stiff well thanks Deb but yeah
man I get that hit boy because I'm gonna
stranger to that to that uh to that dick
game man you know I'm saying if I feel
like it might even just be a crazy night
out hell I throw a five million cialis
under my system just going to lunch if
I'm gonna go to the mall I mean hey dude
I've been out there were you go on a
date you think things are going well you
know you pop five six seven eight
Millie's you know she running a little
bit with a little bit of lift you know
and and then the day goes sour so now
you're running on about you know twenty
two dollars worth of uppers worth of
[ __ ] uppers and you're out in the wild
so I don't want to say like you don't
turn into like a rapist of course but
you definitely turn into somebody who's
trying to get their value out of their
medication and I don't know what that
makes you really I don't know what that
makes me really but yeah man I've been
out there dude just just lift it you
know out there just diving boarding at
the mall or after a dinner you drop the
date off she wasn't interested you
thought it was going one way next thing
you know you just wheeling around town
with that you know caught up with that
third femur you know you got that gift
boy you got that blood gift in you cat
and that's wild and that makes you feel
you're not a superhero but you
definitely you looking ass off your
special powers if you can find a lady
that's interested so I wonder is there
is there any you know it doesn't say
that on the Box really it doesn't say if
the date you're planning on they just
got to people on a mountaintop in a
bathtub and it doesn't say if you're
planning on being wild and it doesn't
work out what do you do with that boner
then you know because it's out there
what else
we got the 25th anniversary of the first
ever text message is coming up do you
realize that the 25th anniversary of the
first ever text message that's this week
and the first ever text message was
Merry Christmas
pretty beautiful huh that's nice
the first thing anyone ever seen anybody
over text was Merry Christmas
it's a nice thought now 25 years later
more than seven hundred and eighty
billion text messages are sent every
year in the United States alone and some
of them probably is depicts you know and
I don't use my own dick pic if I sent a
dick as my buddy Jason Tebow and he got
a decent [ __ ] on him over there and he's
a comedian and he sold me to dick pics
actually this year and some might up my
game and buy another to next year pin it
on you know what's happening and stuff
oh but we're gonna get into a couple of
calls here man
you know I didn't have a big plan for
this episode and I guess I don't really
have to you know I start feeling some
pressure like I got to have a plan
sometimes with the podcast as we go on
but I mean my main goal every week just
needs to be you know just to keep it
going and to show up and I appreciate
you guys showing up listenership is
growing and and people are part of this
community it's good and we've had a good
year and we did some cool stuff you know
we've helped some people we've shared
some topics we've got some voice out
there some people's voices I got two
beautiful thank-you notes this week I
had somebody drop off a gift at the
comedy club for me I haven't even opened
it yet I'm waiting till Christmas
this young lady Lauren thank you so much
it's just been good man I've had my
buddy Ken
Kevin best has helped me make the shirts
you know the onward shirts that are now
available in the store you can check
them out it's just it's been a good year
and I know a lot of that to you guys for
showing up and being a part of my life
this year and uh you know I'm thankful
you know this has been when I look back
on my life you know sometimes I don't
really no you know what I've done and I
don't really feel you know I have to
feel I have to feel like I have to be
constantly reminded you know I need
constant proof that I'm okay or that I
am doing things are doing my job I mean
some people would look and be like oh
man you're so lucky you're like I'm
talking to my buddy Brian he's like
you're so lucky you know your life like
you seem like you have it all on this
and that and then Here I am you know and
I don't even want to get out of bed even
though I have a great day ahead of me
full of people that love me and people
that I love
and uh you know so that's maybe what
some of what we're doing here for each
other you know and I think we're gonna
try to get back to you know I'm gonna
look I'm gonna listen over the holidays
and listen to the different episodes
from the year and see what worked and
what didn't and I'm always open to you
guys as constructive criticism always
you know we're this is we're trying to
do this [ __ ] together whatever it is so
make sure to you know hit up in the
youtube comments or whatever I and and
thank you guys
now I will say this we had a call last
week from at two weeks ago from Adam
Wright I'm a replay Adams call because
Adam called in this week and was not
happy about other responses that we gave
him let's hear Adams some of the replay
from Adams original call about
pornography and and gang banging in
house more hey what's up Theo my name is
Adam and got a little question for you
maybe get your thoughts on a little
little something some in the dark arts
that I've been my wife at about year two
informed me that watching pornography
was akin to cheating okay so Adams call
enough to get thoughts his wife thinks
inform him in year two watching
pornography is akin to cheating let's
hear more she requested that I stop
watching that pornography she wants you
off that porn
okay and so I did
but what she did for me was she allowed
me to start filming us doing the nasty
so she doesn't want you watching it but
she's now okay with you directing and
producing it in house with her own word
uh making that sweet love and oh yeah
dick tricks and all of it man I've seen
it all on the web that's got me through
you know it got me it gets me through
those you know those dry spells you run
into so anyway the dark arts part of
this comes in with me I kind of want to
film her banging somebody else okay so
you want that assassin boy you know you
want that gun or you want that hitter
swinging off the uh you know sweat
jumping off the bookshelf you want that
brother you know with that erection
jumping off the bookshelf and just Swan
and up any wife's trap you know into
that ph-balanced trap you know hopefully
let's hear more anyway man I'd like to
know your thoughts on that you know is
asking her to do that or eventually
maybe even getting her to do that what
you think had kind of a an effect that
might have on the old marriage okay
there you go that was Adams original
call right so we had callers call in
last week on the Thursday episode I
believe it was and give Adam their
thoughts because I put that out to
everyone mr. Adam because I didn't have
experience you know I mean I made love
to a couple girls that were you know
we're cousins I guess in Indiana one
time you know definitely at the end by
the end of it all they were at least
closer than they were before that's for
sure but and then to another time in
Missouri I had a woman you know a hottie
and this other little lady was kind of
this sort of you know kind of polis or
Baltic sort of barbell lift and looking
young lady
you know want to get into something wild
before we hit the air at 4:00 I had a
and then I had to hitch a ride from them
to the airport and the one had a drive
didn't get as much you know Wiener
treatment as much as the first one so
the one that had a drive she was feeling
left out you know and dude the irony I
kid you not I remember you know the
barbell is the one that was on them
barbells you know you ever see the
barbells I have like a hundred hundred
written on the side or a thousand she
look like one of them ladies you know
wearing a unitard kind of you know she
was jacked up you know
neck bone connected to the connected to
the calf muscle you know I'm saying she
was bowed up she had that Emmitt Smith
kind of you know back strap but she she
had to drive me and not and then the hot
one sitting up an air you know in a
shotgun feeling all pleasured out you
know feeling empty a little bit feeling
like somebody just you know poured a
couple a cup of you know room
temperature T right between her legs you
know feeling really kept up and and
satisfied and then the you know that
Wrangler that hit her she's having to
drive us to the airport and she had a
stick shift dude and I could tell that
every time she touched that stick shift
it just reminded her some of that see
that she you know some of that extra you
know that mahogany wean or that strength
that I did that she didn't get and I
feel bad about it a little bit I should
have you know done 50/50 and you should
do that in a threesome kind of deal but
anyhow so you said so those were my only
things I could offer to you mister Adam
but then you came in this was but other
callers had other thoughts they gave you
thoughts on what they was pornography
cheating they gave and they were all
over the place I felt like and they were
you know some people say well whatever
your wife says is cheating that's what's
cheating poor somewhere it's definitely
not cheating somewhere it is cheating if
your wife says so one caller said that
you well let's hear what let's hear what
Adam said cuz then Adam called back
after hear in that episode this was
Adams calling a CEO what's up this is
Adam I am your color that apparently you
had a whole show about my call and I
just got done watching it
and kind of off-put by the callers you
put through a bunch of haters bunch of
jealous
haters dang Adam coming in his ovens
already preheated for he got on the
phone huh
he already bacon bread let's go calling
in to condemn me for what I want to do
in the privacy of my own bedroom with my
wife and just to dispel a few fictions
that were made up about me by your
callers and some by you torn up okay he
throw instance but no I appreciate your
call Adam I do appreciate this call
I appreciate the response I am intrigued
let's hear more pornography was never a
problem with me I had watched it
occasionally the reason my wife said it
was akin to cheating is because she saw
it on my phone one time when she got in
my phone okay we didn't know that let's
hear more wasn't a regular watcher of it
but like I said it got me through you
know a few dry spells here and there but
you had all these callers calling in
condemning me telling me I was crazy
telling me I had six issues and all this
stuff and first off you know let me let
me clarify some things for some people I
have a happy marriage I have a secure
marriage swag urge my wife and I are
freaks together so it wouldn't be
something that she would completely
freak out about gang gang but you know
you call this a safe space and then I
listen to your show and it's nothing but
just haterade pouring out your lines
with all these bitter women Colin it's
just that it man
bitter women I mean I felt like it and
there were some ladies that called and I
thought that they had a female
perspective for you you know I don't
think did just I didn't find him to be
bitter I felt like they were genuinely
concerned let's hear some more Adam
after hearing all your calls I decided
not to talk to my wife about the whole
bringing somebody
then maybe it's not a good idea I heard
one caller say that you know it's a it's
a murderer waiting to happen or some
crazy [ __ ] and so you're saying you
decide let's see so you just you then
went with their advice even though there
were all these people crazy
you went with their advice here more
anyway
disappointed at the show and
disappointed in you for kind of piling
on with all your other [ __ ] callers so
I think he now he's now he's uh counting
chromosomes now you counting somes on
people Wow
I'll still listen to you you're still my
favorite comedian I love what you do but
your callers can suck a dick and he's
still trying to get more sex at the end
there you hear that offering his own
[ __ ] out at the end Adam I appreciate
your call man and I'm gonna tell you
first of all I thought about this man I
even took a couple of notes first of all
there was some misinformation okay
because we didn't know that your wife
was a freak you know we didn't know you
was that you was dating a wild cat you
know we thought you had a Smitten Kitten
at the house you know you said your wife
didn't want you to you know or had
called you out for watching pornography
after two years of marriage so that
makes we're picturing you know we're
picturing a little Fraulein in the
kitchen she got the apron you know you
know says save it for marriage on it you
know knitted into it by her grandmother
she's you know we're picturing a Smitten
Kitten
you know she's at the home you know you
know welding homemade jingle bells maybe
it'll be the craziest thing she ever
does is welding homemade jingle bells in
the in the garage you know one year when
she's feeling wild you know instead of
you know going into lesbianism after you
guys have been married for 15 years or
whatever she gets that out of her system
by welding homemade jingle bells heavy
bells you know some Deen odors in the in
the garage one year and that's how she
gets it out of her system we pictured
that you know we pictured that sort of a
of a vibe of a woman I believe and then
also so we didn't know that she was you
know that she was
had that Cruella de Vil in her you know
she did we didn't know she had 101
Dalmatians trying to get up in that age
you know we didn't know she was like
that so for one there was misinformation
and that's okay look I like a freak you
know I like somebody that don't mind
doing some things or showing out some
things you know somebody that you know
let you get in a carport every now and
then even though you already you know in
the garage but when you hurt when I
think when the audience heard you asking
me for thoughts or suggestions about
jerking off about cheating and I didn't
have them then I put it over to them
you know and that's the thing it's like
maybe I should have said hey I don't
have maybe I should say on the hotline
and this is for anybody hitting the
hotline from now on that this call a
call could be put out to other people
you know and I'm sorry so I do apologize
for that man if I you know if you didn't
want it put out to the masses like that
for other people's thoughts then I am
sorry because I you know I didn't really
let that know be known and I'll make
that clear from now on and I hope
listeners understand that and the
hotline is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and all you guys
knew that I was gonna drop that hotline
number right there to all the elders
sitting like how bad he gonna drop this
but I was crowdsourcing I put it out to
the audience you know and I thought they
did a good job I thought most people had
your care or concern I thought you know
I thought it was pretty supportive you
know it said the one lady just say you
might get murdered but the more I
thought about it you're talking to an
avid Dateline watcher okay but what
about that can opener you know my buddy
Jeff Richards he does a good
impersonation of the old white guy from
one of the Dateline episodes and I'm
paraphrasing but he's like but what
about that kind opener it was usually in
the draw so summer came in summer turned
to winter and winter turned to fall and
fall turn to
box day but now you gotta check him out
but anyhow so we did that man we did
what I felt like we did but I wanted to
apologize if I let it be crowdsourcing
you didn't want it but you called out
that lady said you thought you might get
murdered I'm gonna play a part of her
call really really quick because I
thought that her call was really
accurate and you'll probably like in six
months be dead because like this is the
beginning of like how murder mystery
start bro like it all started when Adam
said hey I want you to you know have sex
with my friend like Steve then Stephen
Adams wife had a thing on the side where
she was like oh no I don't like Steve
but she did like Stephen and like Oh
Adams got like life insurance and now
bro you just cut yourself out of the
equation that's it and if you don't
think that's a recipe for disaster then
I don't think you would have agreed with
them at the end Adam so I'm gonna take
you to task on that but it's been a
journey man you know you wanted it and I
believe that our audience gave you some
really good suggestions and good
thoughts you know but I do appreciate
you calling in about it and I appreciate
your call back in and I'm sorry that you
felt you know if you got misled a little
bit and I didn't mean that
you know I'm no Mis leader you know I
try to leave bread crumbs and that's for
both of us to get home you know I'm not
hit I'm not out here you know Hansel and
by myself you know you're my Gretel
brother you know but Adam boy you know
that's how it goes I'm even even in the
Bible if you go back to Adam you know
you wanted to get that fruit what
happened you want to get that fruit you
want to taste that pear you want to get
that little lily and put it in your
mouth you know you want to pick up pig's
foot off the branch and next thing you
know you won't have a barbeque in the
back of your throat but you don't want
to face the consequences well that young
lady that called up said you might get
murdered she she's a woman that's a
woman's perspective you know and I can't
give you that woman's perspective you
know even if I do my vag on Megami and
you know and even if I try and you know
put on a skirt or some type of a cotton
something
or some polyester breasts arm [ __ ]
tankini or something I'm not gonna offer
you that so that's why we outsource tit
but oh oh I don't know you know I I
don't even know sometimes I don't even
know sometimes man I'm thinking about
the holidays I'm thinking about some of
the food I want to see some more food
man that's what I want
damn I want some damn whipped cream I
bought a bunch of pears and I'm being
eating pears for the past two days and
I'm I'm tired of eating pears man I
really am so we got one more call the we
had a caller that called in earlier this
year and it was called it up and I guess
afraid to play for you and I'm not gonna
play it now but I'm gonna play it later
this I'm gonna play it on the next
episode on next Sundays I think and uh
and I should have got to it before it
was about something happened between me
and them on the road and I'll get to it
next episode and uh but first I got one
more call came in right here and I'm
gonna put this er here we go yeah video
Jared from Boston here again waiting on
that snow to do some snow plow I know
you got hit down there your family got
hit down there in Louisiana yeah yeah
that's true
they got that snow down there you know
they got that snow down Louisiana and my
niece they sent me a picture of my niece
was down there on a quad on a
four-wheeler out there just doing donuts
out in her yard and she's only eight or
nine years old so you know she's pretty
brave little lady out there to be
quadding out there like that but that
was uh she's a ballsy little lady if any
of you ladies out there have good advice
on what to get like kind of a country
girl who are children these are children
nine and eight eight and maybe six I
think my nieces are nine and seven and
I'm trying to think of some cute kind of
stuff that they're really smart they you
know they just like they're kind of
country girls if anybody has a good gift
or a suggestion for them maybe email it
to me if you can and that's just a fee
of an th EO vo in
matcom ma c-calm and let's finish up
this guy's call here we go got their
little dog blanket coming at you keepin
y'all nice and cozy and I'm gonna be
doing some flower I'll be doing some
listening so just want to say god damn
you a handsome young man thinking about
dressing you up in a little dress a
little wig
oh man he trying to get me feeling
special you hear him he trying to
rearrange the fridge and uh take me off
that busy shelf and put me in that
crisper drawer you know what I'm talking
about
taking you taking a walk through the
woods but I ain't gonna show you a
grandma's house let me show you those
something else yeah I'm saying kids you
know people can plow we ain't doing we
doing some snow clowns doing some
talents a little bootie you know but
damn he got frets there at the end of
that part huh more but uh ain't really
gay bro but if I was gay I'd be all up
in that ass deal you were damn handsome
man
dang dude look if you gay or not man
it's okay and if you if that's what you
got to do to get it out of your system
sometime call another man and leave a
voicemail telling you gonna sneak him
off into the woods I mean you really
described the evening mr. Boston you
really described the evening mr. Boston
about being sex in doing sex and doing
it and you know getting out of there and
trying to skeet between my cheeks like
that you know I'm being dark you know
we're trying to get all brownie browned
out you know that's that but he talking
about the booty time you know and yeah I
don't know if you ever knew this but
that song uh brown eyed girl that's
always about uh doing you know backdoor
sex if you don't realize that hey where
did we go days when the rains came down
in the hollow play in a new game
come on laughing in a runnin skipping in
a jumping you're my brown-eyed girl come
on man
playing a new game y'all know that you
know what's going on out there but look
buddy we all have to do something to get
it out of our system every now and then
you know sometimes I used to go to
Quiznos I need a big sandwich and when
you open your mouth on that toasty bread
and I've talked about this before and
you lock eyes with another mayonnaise
you can feel the squirrels run you know
you can feel that huh
you know you can feel that homosexuality
just kind of temper three-three through
your shoulders and shake out shake down
Street man you can feel your neck swirl
a little and that's okay you know that
Quiznos gives you that you got to let
the squirrels run a little bit you know
sometime you got a you know you got to
do something you got to touch your
buddy's neck while he's sleeping you
know and hold on to your nuts with the
other hand at the same time so Nome you
got to get that whatever it is to get
that out of you you know where to get
order to let it thrive I'm speaking from
a straight males perspective you know I
might do gay when I'm at 70 or 80 but
for now I'm doing straight and I'm have
a family I'm gonna do all of it you know
but I'll look at gayness when I'm later
I'm in no hurry a lot of these gay dudes
trying to get you to be gay right now
back up buddy not interested you know
they say it's a choice it's not a choice
you know gay dudes always like it's not
a choice man it's nature I believe its
nature as well so then quit trying to
get me to choose it bro you know my gay
friends sneaky dude you know you get
home take off your pants after a night
out and you find a gig a buddy be in
your pants like um what you doing in
there Sidney so you got us some time
watch for that sneak man but you can't
blame them they're men but it but that's
that you guys hit the hotline we're
gonna do a Thursday episode talking
about Christmases around the world if
you have a special Christmas story or
something a unique tradition that
happens at your house on Christmas why
don't you give that to us ladies I love
to hear from some of you ladies too
about what's going on out there what do
you think about this about to show to
you if are we to mail or you know what
can we do to you know I love having a
female perspective
you know because a lot of times in my
life growing up I didn't have one and
even if I did have one I couldn't hear
it I just couldn't I couldn't absorb a
few more specs of like I wanted to so if
we got some women out there that want to
drop some stuff in newest if anyone
wants to hit the hotline its nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
please hit it up
anybody out there struggling anything
anything you think if I can share any of
my experience you know any of my
strengths any of my hope I'm happy to do
it
and thank you guys so much for being
here with me today man I feel better not
joking a hundred percent if you're only
YouTube right now you can see me I got
on a Christmas shirt I wore a Christmas
shirt just for you and I honestly I feel
better and I am very I want to say thank
you because you know if you don't show
up for me this year then I wouldn't be
showing up for myself I wouldn't be
showing up for you right now to get this
done and uh and that's teamwork man you
know constantly amazed at what happens
when you know when we show up for
ourselves or when we show up for other
people you know I'm constantly amazed at
what happens when uh you know just when
we connect you know when we connect to
just more things happen you know and I'm
happy I appreciate it I'm happier imma
go my buddy's gonna be here in about ten
minutes we got a little squad beautiful
crew and we're gonna head over and see
mr. James Blake he's a really soulful
musician and how they packed all this
you know how they packed so much Urbanus
into a into a white gentleman man it's
baffling so if he ever breaks open I
have a feeling they're gonna have a
whole suite family of sisters are gonna
come just rollin out of his rib cage but
I'm happy I appreciate you guys being
here I'm gonna take you out one of our
callers said to let the music play so
I'm gonna let this play here's a here's
my Kevin wakes up in the morning for
Christmas on home alone here's my
somebody pulling a big bird out of you
is if you've been laws or something like
that and you at the ready med are you at
the
emergency care here we go be good to
yourselves guys I hope you deserve it
I bet you do thank you very much
happy holidays I'll see you on Thursday
love you creeps
[Music]
you